[Music]
hello everybody
yep how would you like to be a walrus
well since you have to understand
something
since the since the dawn of man when he
was crawling up
out of the mud he has always wanted
to know the answer you know is it better
to be
know what how how did it go [ __ ] no i
can't never should man
should man is man better be better off
being a walrus or something like that i
don't remember exactly what he said
walrus at heart yeah
[Laughter]
i gotta see it again this movie you guys
yeah
i gotta see it again this is the second
time i've seen it
um first time i saw it i really liked it
it was just [ __ ] tripped me the [ __ ]
out
second time i was watching it i it was
dawning on me that this movie's a
masterpiece
it's a masterpiece it's a divisive film
for sure
but i don't know there's something i
really really liked about dialogue is
[ __ ] fantastic
the the story arc of
the story is [ __ ] great just the
philosophy behind the [ __ ] villain in
the movie and
everything that happens it's it's very
unexpected and it's just
really weird and you go like yeah that's
some weird [ __ ] man
that's a weird [ __ ] it is yeah yeah so
you guys haven't seen this movie man i
don't really want to spoil it i know
well i don't know because i kind of feel
like this is kind of one of those things
where it's kind of like
um human centipede where it's like even
if you haven't seen it like you pretty
much know what the premise is
and if you've like seen the pictures
well okay so
our kind of oh uh happy monday and happy
memorial day uh
you know everybody when i saw this i
didn't know the premise
well yeah see that's what i was going to
say our history with this movie
we were like shauna and eric were over
at our house and we were having a movie
day or whatever
and shauna said to us you guys you have
to watch this movie and it's
just called tusk and that's all we knew
she's like that's all i'm gonna tell you
uh is the title of it so it's on netflix
i don't know if it still is
and uh just watch it i didn't know it
was kevin smith movie i didn't know
anything about it like i didn't know
what it was about so we just like
watched it
and this is definitely one if you
haven't seen it this is definitely one
of those what the [ __ ] am i watching
boobies but in a good way yeah but like
i said not everybody
is gonna hang with it because i've seen
like some reviews of it like some people
really really dug it
some people liked the first half but not
the second half some people thought it
was totally inconsistent
some people didn't like um
the uh the cameo that's in it like the
big famous person that's in there
cameoing uh the character that he's
playing that didn't bother me so much i
can see why that maybe would get on
people's nerves but it didn't really
bother me that much
so all right so the story behind this
uh movie was that kevin smith uh he has
a podcast
called smodcast and on this particular
show
which was called the walrus and the
carpenter they had come across
thank you mr roboto was uh was justin
long supposed to be a villain
in tusk i guess he was in the sense that
i mean he was just kind of a dick like
but he wasn't enough of a dick to
deserve what had happened to him
so i will say that so i don't know if he
was the villain i think howard was the
villain obviously the question was
was he better off as a walrus
that was the question well he he was
more human
as a as a walrus he had he had a soul
that's the question that mankind has
always wanted to know are you better off
as a walrus
[Laughter]
some people may be recording the answer
may be yeah according to the crazy
[ __ ] i call him a villain
he's crazy [ __ ] of course he's a
villain he's serious he's a serial
killer
so yeah he's a bad guy howard yeah
and uh he had quite a philosophy
i don't know he lies a lot i don't know
if the walrus story actually happened or
if he thinks it happened
oh yeah because he was crazy [ __ ]
crazy
so you don't know if any of the [ __ ]
that he said was true i have a feeling
he's lies about everything i think it
was all delusion
yeah which that's totally possible yeah
but um
but yeah so apparently so okay so on
this podcast episode which was called
the walrus and the carpenter
kevin smith had come across this uh
craigslist
ad i don't know if it was craigslist or
something like craigslist and the ad
basically said um hey i'm looking for
someone like
it's a living situation you can stay in
my house for free
if and it had this whole story about
i've made a realistic walrus suit
and you would be required to be in the
walrus suit for two hours every day
and then you can stay in the house for
free so they read this post like on the
podcast and they thought it was so
funny that then they just went off and
wrote this whole entire pretty much
movie
like about like from this person or this
ad
and then they got so amused by it like
because they were talking about human
centipede and all that kind of stuff
like yeah we could totally make it like
that and so they were just like kind of
bullshitting back and forth
and then at the end of it they said hey
maybe we should make this into a movie
and so they told all their fans they say
hey put hashtag walrus yes
if you want us to make it into a movie
or hashtag walrus no if you don't want
us to make it into a movie
and overwhelmingly everybody wanted it
made it to a movie so they made it into
a movie
and then it came out later on that the
ad the original ad that they had uh
you know found on craigslist or wherever
was a joke so the person that had
written the ad like to be funny like
contacted them and i guess he got like
an executive producer or associate
producer credit like on the movie
because he was the one that came up with
the idea hey come and live in my house
and like i'm gonna make you dress up
like a walrus
yeah the movie costs 2.8
million dollars to make you wouldn't
know it by looking at it it's a
masterpiece
it's a [ __ ] spooky [ __ ] weird-ass
movie
that asks a bunch of questions you know
about the nature of man now you know
these questions are [ __ ] asked by a
[ __ ] lunatic
all right but it's still a good idea you
know
i don't want to get into the dude's
backstory too much it's just that
he made these claims that when he was
young he got lost at sea
and ended up on a small island and the
only thing that was there to protect him
was a big strong
male walrus that kept him warm mr
tusk and they had a great friendship
and make a long story short he misses
his
friend and his relationship that he had
with the walrus
so he wants to recreate that in his
palatial mansion
he's got this big ass [ __ ] house out
in the middle of nowhere really in
canada
yeah it's in manitoba so he had a bunch
of money and he had a whole bunch of
stories about him and ernest hemingway
and see so you don't know he's quoting
rhyme with the ancient man
yeah he's real well educated but i think
it's all lies
he said that he was on d-day but he
doesn't look old enough to be on d-day
um that although you know you know yeah
he
i don't think he was old enough and uh
just [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] you know what i
mean he's
he he he can't get his walrus friend
back
so he's a serial killer that's
transforming men into walruses
into wall rye wall right yeah
he's got a whole little dungeon set up
with a [ __ ]
pool and a fake island and his
version of [ __ ] virtual reality he's
got that
camera projectors projecting maritime
[ __ ] backgrounds and scenery like
he's out on the ocean
and he wants to just hang out with his
walrus friend on the little island and
sing songs and [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] weird [ __ ] happens man
yeah this is definitely a really really
weird
he explains there's a block
i have to see it again fully catch
everything
it had to do with the fact that modern
men are
corrupt and evil and weak they did bad
things to him when he was in an
orphanage
an orphanage that got turned into a
mental asylum
and then he says that the priests and
the nuns raped him and everybody raped
him and
had things in his mouth that no kid
should have in his mouth
and you don't know if it's lies or not i
have a feeling he's delusional on
everything
well yeah because you kind of find out
later that he's like a serial killer
yeah that he's done it before yeah i
think it's all in his mind
but he said the humans are bad humans
are really bad and corrupt
but not walrus are good they're pure at
heart
yeah and mankind is better off as a
walrus
you know it's just some weird [ __ ] and
walrus have
walrus have uh survival instincts and
they're not [ __ ] each other over
and you know they're not worried about
[ __ ] like money and
careers it's just bizarre man
so he sets upon the task of
transforming the man into a walrus
yeah and it's not just like yeah he's
built like a walrus suit out of
skin it looks like a patch together skin
like some
texas chainsaw yeah but he also cuts you
up and turns you into shape of a walrus
yeah kind of so you can fit in there
better yeah it gives you tusks and
everything but
that's going the way that that's going
and then it makes you eat the way a
walrus
[Laughter]
teaches you to swim the way this wall
it's all an act of love okay
it's [ __ ] bizarre man it's a good
movie
i still remember the first time we
watched this movie because like i said
the first time we watched this i had no
idea what it was about i didn't know it
was kevin smith i didn't know like what
kind of movie it was i didn't know if it
was straight up horror if it was
i mean it's essentially it's a black
comedy uh is what it is
but um like i said how you feel about
i don't know like to me it's just the
the humor of this like really kind of
uh really kind of that was like right in
my wheelhouse because it's like the
the humor is just like so [ __ ] up in
this and honestly
i loved all the acting in this was
really really good
like [ __ ] justin long was great in
this he was like such a douche
like at the beginning um and because the
whole reason that he ends up in canada
is because him and haley joel osment uh
you know grown up obviously not not the
kid from the sixth sense which is a
movie we just uh talked about
uh you know that that'll come out later
this week but uh they have a pot
they have a podcast and it's called the
not
see party but if you say it fast it
sounds like nazi party so every time
like somebody tries to like kind of say
hey we we have a podcast that's not
seaparty.com so it says like dodger
definitely hangs up on him yeah it's
like that kind of [ __ ] cause he i guess
he thinks he's being edgy or whatever
so they have that and their whole shtick
is they
try to interview people that have
humiliated themselves in viral videos
so their latest thing is like there's
this kid who went viral as the kill bill
kid
and he was doing all these moves with a
katana and cut his own leg off
and so um so wallace who's the main
character played by justin long
he's going to go to canada and interview
this kid um
and kind of make fun of him you know
what i mean because that's what he does
because he's
kind of a jerk yeah this guy is like
kind of like the personification of the
[ __ ] modern
[ __ ] california american
douchebag [ __ ] he's a douche he's a
podcaster
i didn't say he was a youtuber though
yeah just uh yeah he's a podcaster
yeah and he's just real superficial
real when his whole shtick is like being
cruel and just
mocking people that's kind of the whole
like uh thing of their show
yeah i guess he thinks it's cruel it's
not cruelty on a scale that would
[ __ ] you know upset me he's it's just
being a dick he thinks he's just being
real edgy
yeah and he just comes off being like a
[ __ ] dick
yeah and uh he's real kind of like
california culture is the center of his
[ __ ] world
he doesn't like canada he doesn't want
to die in canada he's sucking just
real mainstream commercial
run-of-the-mill california [ __ ]
douche he's like one of those who's
trying to get famous
on the backs of other people and on the
backs of stepping on people and
kind of ridicule and the misfortune or
the unfortunate you know
it but he does all kinds of other [ __ ]
too he cheats on his girlfriend
and [ __ ] just real shallow
superficial
yeah yeah you could kind of like
something out of [ __ ] mainstream
hollywood
that's what they've done well yeah he's
a poser too he's a total fake he's a
fake poser
so he goes like so he goes to canada to
interview this kid but when he gets
there he finds out that the kid has
committed suicide because of all the
ridicule that he's been getting online
so he's so uh wallace is pissed because
he's like man i flew all the way up to
[ __ ] manitoba canada
and now i don't have anything for the
show like he's like that he keeps
calling that kid that selfish little
[ __ ] for like killing himself because
he's like
we're killing himself so he can't be on
my show you know who this guy reminds me
of who's that that guy we were on his
[ __ ] radio show in california
yeah i guess i mean that was such a long
time ago yeah it was like that 70 iq
really [ __ ] superficial humor it's
just you know you can't it feels like
you're
dealing with children and these are
grown men yeah yeah
he reminds me of that so he goes up
there
and then i mean he's just this i don't
know he's just like a real entitled
prick or whatever
so he's in this bar um trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] he's gonna do and he's
like he spent all this money flying up
there and now he doesn't have anything
so he finds this big long letter which
is very much like the original uh
craigslist ad that they read on the
podcast
you know saying oh i have all these
stories and he's like oh hey i'll go to
this
old dude's house and you know at least
i'll have some weird outlet to like talk
to
yeah it doesn't see anything about where
about a walrus though well obviously
that because that'd be like
you know right it's just an invitation
to somebody to live
with him and he wants to tell his
stories because he's in there he's old
you need somebody to do chores and he
can't take care of it but
you know that it's a nice place and if
you live there and
listen to his stories you don't you'll
be rent free yeah
and you just do some chores except
that's not exactly how it turns out yeah
he just goes there he doesn't want to
stay there he goes there he just wants
to hear these stories for his podcast
probably with the intent of making fun
of us all dude well yeah that's like i
said that's kind of the whole premise of
his podcast is just making fun of
weirdos yeah um so that's
absolutely why he goes yeah it doesn't
work out
but what's interesting about it though
is that i really
really liked and honestly like justin
long uh he's been in but he's been in a
lot of horror movies he was actually
even in one of the uh
that creep show that we saw the other
day and he's actually kind of an
underrated actor he's really really good
in this
yeah and the fact that he comes across
as such a douche at the beginning
and even though you kind of want him to
like to
you know to have something bad happen to
him the [ __ ] that happens to him
um as much of an [ __ ] as he is
it's just like way way beyond the pale
so you actually end up feeling like
really bad for him by the end even
though he's a total like
always in there he's another california
guy you know i grew up
in the early part of california he says
he says there's douches and then there's
california douches yeah
there's this guy's a california douche
they're always emulating the [ __ ]
emulating hollywood trying to make it
big
you know it's just part of being a
douche yeah yeah
um but yeah so so i feel like it's
really it's really weird because i think
that
this is one of those movies you either
kind of love it or you hate it
you know what i mean because i feel like
there was a lot of people that really
really didn't like it or really didn't
hang with it it's pretty [ __ ] up
but the first half of it is like this
really good
creepy i mean there's humor in it but
there's really good like weird
like suspense building up because you're
not entirely sure how it's going to go
people didn't like this movie well it's
i don't know about that well some people
were like
and i saw some [ __ ] there was like a lot
of horror fans and a lot of people
liked it like during the build up but
then they thought that
they're like oh well then it just kind
of went too silly like toward the end or
it didn't really like hang together
yeah but i don't necessarily like i said
everyone's got their opinion about it
and
you know but i actually thought i just
didn't get it
well it's not so much that it's like not
everybody that doesn't like a movie does
that
just doesn't get it some people just
don't like it and it's like that's fine
but i'm just saying that i thought
tonally it worked really well because
like i said the tone of it is kind of
the first half
you know when he first gets to the old
guy's house and the guy's telling him
all the stories and everything
you know something bad is going to
happen but you don't know exactly what
and you don't know exactly how it's
going to play out
and then once he gets turned into a
walrus it kind of like
it goes in a different direction it's
almost kind of like
funny and over the top but then it's
also kind of like really
unsettling and off-putting at the same
time because there's a lot of like body
horror in it that was the idea
yeah that's what i mean so so you know
how you feel about that
i saw one reviewer that said something
like they said they they actually really
really liked the movie but they said
they
that they wish that he had waited a
little longer to like reveal the walrus
you know what i mean like
he wanted more like more build up but
which i can kind of see that too but
like i said i'm not really bothered by
it
i didn't i think what the deal was is
they didn't want to unveil the walrus
and then then then the the end go down
and then it's over
they wanted you to start identifying
with
the walrus as an individual character
yeah that it was becoming that that that
guy had become a walrus
yeah that's the idea and you know like
you said i think kind of the thing about
it was that almost in a [ __ ] up way he
was almost like a better person as a
walrus
yeah i think they were trying to say
that the dude that did it to him was
kind of right
[Laughter]
even though he was a serial killer yeah
that didn't necessarily mean he was
wrong
it just meant that some people because
their [ __ ] bags
would have more soul and more character
if they were a walrus
versus because as a human they're just
a piece of [ __ ] yeah he was the guy
basically what he said he's a garbage
person
but he'd make a great wall that's the
that's the thing he did make it because
you know
you can't fix that like what what he did
to that dude you can't fix it
yeah and i think he internalized
walrusness towards the end
because at the end he was eating the
fish and his girlfriend said i love you
he's still in the cage and you know and
he's crying
a little bit but are they the tears of a
man
or are they the tears of a woman
that's the way i was looking at it you
know i think they were the tears of a
walrus
it's it was kind of like a turnabout as
a fair play
he was kind of a garbage person and it
was kind of like humiliating the weak
yeah basically and then they turned he
turned out he was weak
and he was kind of
he ended up being the butt of the joke
he lost his humanity
but his humanity wasn't [ __ ] anyway but
he kind of gained the ability of being a
walrus
that's what i think it was trying to say
david june said he had to go full walrus
yeah he went for a while because before
he didn't have any survival instincts he
went full walrus
he didn't he couldn't come back from it
so this is i don't know because i know
that this was um
that kevin smith made another movie like
in this
proposed trilogy because this is tusk
this is the first one this came out in
2014
14. then there was a second one called
yoga hosers which came out in 2016
which i don't know if it's completely
interlinked but it's like the same
cast and i think it's also set in canada
um i haven't seen that one
i've heard real mixed reviews about that
one too but i guess that's kind of true
of any kevin smith movie
and he was supposed to make a third one
called moose jaws
which was like jaws but with a moose um
but i don't think that one's been made
yet
but that's the third one that's the
third proposed one that he wants to make
uh so he's making all these movies up in
canada there's actually on the disc
which david june
very uh very nicely sent to us a while
back and i'm sorry it's taken us this
long to get around to it
but uh there was actually a really long
interview with
kevin smith where he was just talking he
was talking a little bit about this but
he was also just kind of talking about
his career in general and i have to say
that
even if you don't love a lot of his
movies and there's some of his movies
that i haven't
seen yet you know what i mean i've seen
like some of his older ones i saw clerks
i saw chasing amy i saw him maul rats i
saw all that
um i still haven't seen red state i
probably need to get around to that as
well
but he just seems like a just a good
dude
i mean he just seems like an all-around
good-hearted
humble person who got
lucky in a lot of ways because he made
clerks for next to nothing
and it resonated with so many people
that he ended up having this career in
it and he just
he just seems like a like a cool like
regular dude you know what i mean
i remember we used to watch uh comic
book men sometimes that was actually a
really good show
what i thought was weird about this show
is after they rescue him though is that
they kept him in a walrus suit
the human wall were suited well maybe he
couldn't i don't think that
that you could get him out of it he
couldn't get it out of it well i mean
it had somehow bonded to him or he was
sewn in there or
something it was weird how it kind of
his
face had been replaced somehow and it
kind of blended into the
i don't understand i mean the makeup on
this like the walrus was
really good yeah because the thing about
it was that
however they did it like he had tasks he
had but it was his actual eyes
and his face was just like really really
expressive still
even though it was like his eyes but it
was like a walrus face
yeah and like he had made a walrus body
and somehow put him in there
i don't really and he was all mangled up
well
yeah he cut his legs off and like he
fused his arms like
right like sewed them to his side of his
whatever and he had a whole bunch of
human skin
too he kind of grabbed it onto the
outside i guess it wasn't attached to
his vascular system but
yeah you couldn't get him out of it
somehow for some reason yeah maybe it
i don't yeah i don't really know but
like i said it's not you would reject it
it's not it's just a movie
and they're just [ __ ] with yeah we're
thinking about it too much yeah i was
like how the hell
because i kind of feel like yeah i kind
of love though
that kevin smith they just came up with
this [ __ ] ridiculous ass
idea for a movie just for a minute like
a craigslist ad or whatever because like
listen to this crazy [ __ ]
and then it's like hey let's make a
movie out of it what was great is just
how they come up with a crazy idea like
that and then
they come up with a philosophy that
justifies the idea
which goes to show you that a lunatic
can justify anything
well yeah of course that's what work
that's why they're eliminated if you
work on it long enough you can justify
anything
you know just the premise of this
i was just like man but honestly i can't
remember the name of the guy
who wrote the original ad because for
whatever reason i don't know
like what that dude's motivation was he
just thought it would be funny uh so he
just wrote this whole like
complicated and it was kind of similar
to howard howe's backstory in the
in the movie um you know that oh i was
shipwrecked and i met this walrus and he
was my best friend and stuff i don't
think that like he ate him or anything
like that like in the movie but
it was kind of like this whole backstory
he's like and i miss that walrus so i
want somebody to like
be in this walrus suit for two hours a
day and they can live here for free
mr roboto said that he started with a
walrus face i don't know what you're
talking about dude there were no walrus
parts in there
yeah it was it was all human skin that
was stitched together
yeah and bought to look like a walrus
yeah and bones for his
tusks and [ __ ] well he used
well he used the dude's own bones from
his legs
and he carved them into tests i don't
think they said that outright but that
was the implication
i think they were drilled holes in there
and the other ones yeah because
because uh you know the big he wasn't
the first one
no because yeah when he's in the pool
like he's these other ones because um
you know the the big cameo in this one
actually it's not even a cameo because
it's johnny depp
um in case you didn't know but he's um i
don't want to say he's unrecognizable
because i recognized him but they put
like a fake nose on him and likes of a
mustache and a wig and chill oh
johnny jeff did to the friend you didn't
know that was johnny depp yeah that was
i
immediately did i was joining that um
yeah he was doing like an inspector clue
so coverage which i think was another
thing i think a lot of people didn't
like that character like it just went on
too long and it was like too silly
how the hell did he get johnny depp to
be in this movie because i think
their kids go to the same school or
something like that
like you know like kevin smith's kid
daughter and uh johnny depp's daughter i
think they have daughters that are the
same age i wonder if he got paid for
that
i don't know um i think johnny depp
might have been in yoga hosers too now
that i'm thinking about it but yeah
they're friends because like i think
like i said i think their daughters go
to the same school so i think they met
each other that way
um that's what i heard so he just kind
of like randomly met him and he's like
hey want to be in the movie i don't know
if he was in it for free i don't even
know
i don't even know if he was like in the
credits because he wasn't supposed to be
recognizable like i said i recognized
him but they put like a fake nose on him
and he's playing this he has this like
ridiculous
sort of french accent yeah so it's all
over the place and he's just like and
you kind of get like a lot of backstory
about he's been tracking
this you know serial killer that's like
you know turning people into walruses
all over manitoba and so he comes in
about halfway through the movie and
that's kind of like
[ __ ] i didn't realize this because i
think we turned it off before
um the credits were over but i think
there's an end
uh there's an after credit scene oh
there is because you know
you know where he's where johnny depp is
in the diner
like talking to the girlfriend and
talking to haley joel osment about the
about everything
and he's eaten the hamburgers like and
he gets like a whole bunch of food and
he's eating it and stuff
i think at the very very end there's a
scene of him like
i don't know if he's farting or if he's
just like having like saying that he
shouldn't have eaten that extra
hamburger or something like that
because there's like there's a lot of
kind of kind of lowbrow
like kind of you know gas type of humor
because i think he says
earlier on in the movie he says
something about how something gives him
gas or something like that
yeah kevin and kevin and johnny depp are
semi pals that's what i thought
yeah yoga hosers johnny depp is also in
that
exactly so uh
yeah daniel says i seen an advertisement
for an episode of your podcast about
occult roots of nazism and some extra
stuff is that available i couldn't find
it it's on there somewhere
that's like a really really old one what
we did i thought it wasn't even
we didn't have video for that one i
don't think no but um
i'll see you call it what now he said he
saw an advertisement for it for an
episode and now he can't find it
so i'll have to let me let me look for
it because like i said that's an old
one yeah but let me see
where'd you see an advertisement for
that well it might have been
he might have been meant like it was
recommended like in a recommendation
yeah it should be chili pepper burns has
got yeah i got i got that reference
that's from that [ __ ] movie that was
on mst um
i was sent here for dia de los muertos
chat
i don't know what that means oh okay i
got you
yeah he says thanks jenny okay well
you're welcome but yeah so
i don't remember if this movie is still
on netflix or not i think we initially
watched it on netflix
and i think yoga hosers is on there as
well but i don't know if they're still
there
we watched it on the on blu-ray because
david jin sent it to us
and like i said we had seen it before i
actually i think i liked it even better
the second time
it's a it's a very it's a really really
weird movie and it's really
not one thing or another it's like a
horror movie and it's pretty
it's got some pretty gross like body
horror [ __ ] in it and it's kind of
disturbing
but it's also like funny but it's funny
like in a bizarro
type of way you know what i'm saying and
i really really like i like all the [ __ ]
when he first gets to canada and he's in
that convenience store talking to those
two girls that shit's really funny too
you know what i mean uh tyler says so
few movies i hate this is one of them
like i said i feel like kevin smith's
movies are very very divisive
every single one of them has been super
super divisive
because the dude i mean you got to give
the dude props like i said he seems like
a really nice dude and he
makes pretty much exactly what he wants
to make most of the time
other than the one big hollywood movie
that he did which was called cop-out
from 2010 which i also haven't seen
um but he said he had a pretty good
experience doing that but he'd rather do
like indie movies
um you know but he he just basically
makes whatever he wants and
he doesn't care how weird it is and this
is uh one of the weird ones
sure you have anything else you would
like to add no it's a good movie
yeah it's kind of like something that
would have made up been made for a
really [ __ ]
low budget back in the 70s and had been
made and been made poorly and then have
been forgotten
but he took this crazy idea and kind of
elevated it
i think it's good movie i mean
particularly the first half where he's
in that creepy old house and like all
the scenes with the two of them talking
and like this i mean those are
they're beautiful looking uh shots i
like all of it yeah i do too
i just think it's it's it's it's just
weird it's kind of like it's kind of
like human centipede in a certain
way not not scatological but you know or
whatever it is
not somebody said it's like human
centipede meets misery
yeah but funny yeah
[Laughter]
well you know you're kind of you kind of
feel supposed to feel sorry for the dude
but you're also kind of like
yeah he was kind of a [ __ ] though
you know what i mean but yeah
it's not what happens to him doesn't
really justify and we're not saying that
yeah it's just saying that he wasn't a
very good person
but he might be a better walrus
yeah well i guess well that was that's
that
they were exploring that idea
the movie explores that idea explore the
idea that some people are better than
rawr
that was the idea and like you said
i think he probably was yeah he probably
was
the tears of a walrus
and just the the dude that did it to him
is you know
real philosophical about it
and uh certain [ __ ] has to happen
between him and the walrus to get it
straight because they had
something went down between them that he
has to make right you know it's just
it's just [ __ ]
it's a great idea it is yeah i mean it's
batshit insane but it's great
yeah imagine if you just came up with
some [ __ ] weird-ass tale
you were telling your buddies when you
were [ __ ] drunk or something you know
and you're all laughing about this weird
ass [ __ ] tale
and then you freeze it in time and then
[ __ ] actually make it a movie
that's basically what happened well yeah
that's what they did they were [ __ ]
around on the podcast
like yeah very rarely does anything like
that actually happen
in real life but it happened with this
movie so
nobody else would have made this movie
this movie was not supposed to be made
no it's definitely not cool though yeah
i really liked it yeah
scott says which one of you has more
tattoos i do jenny does probably
um i actually well i have two that still
show
although this one i had another one a
small one underneath it that got covered
up so
technically i have three and i have that
one too and he only has one
no no that's three i have three two
oh okay they weren't all done at the
same time oh okay
all right that's right yeah so
technically it's just i guess because
it's all one i
i forgot that it was like done no we
were adding to it and [ __ ] around
okay uh scott says a lot of people look
like walruses and yoga pants
well there you go that is that is
absolutely true all right
um yeah scott says military yeah he was
uh
yeah he must be new although i've seen
that
i've seen the name before yeah yeah he
was uh he was in the army
yeah so uh all right you have anything
else you would like to add
um no um
no no okay i'm good i'm good shut it
down it was that
that that that's plenty all right uh
we'll be back tomorrow i'm not sure what
movie we're gonna be talking about but
we'll think of something because we have
a whole big pile
are there any female walrus humans i
guess we'll never know he'll have to
make another one
in which a woman gets turned a shitty
woman gets their difficult walrus
they were all men yeah they were well
because i think the original
walrus was mr tusk it i think in the
in the original craigslist post the
walruses name was gregory
okay so just i thought i thought i would
add that like for a fun fact
all right so uh thanks everybody for
dropping by today
we'll be back tomorrow to talk about
another movie so have a good rest of
your day